[Music]
if your smiles a bit lackluster you
could go to the dentist for potent
blasts of tooth whitening but whitening
strips put the same ingredients in a
package for home what's inside these
special strips hydrogen peroxide is the
star of the show it's the same stuff you
bleach your floors with but at a much
lower concentration it breaks apart into
radicals molecules with reactive
unpaired electrons those guys like to
attack stain molecules and break them
apart hydrogen peroxide is an acid which
is why you need sodium hydroxide a base
along with it it makes a strip less
acidic so it's easier to keep in your
mouth sodium saccharin helps balance out
the bleach too it cloaks the bitterness
without cavity causing sugar then
there's the delivery system it starts
with PA G or polyethylene glycol these
chains of carbons and oxygens love
binding to the water in your saliva
creating a layer of sticky gel they also
linked up at the ends to other absorbent
polymers including acrylate copolymer
it's the same stuff that mops up liquid
in disposable diapers it takes up so
much water that it might dehydrate T
which could be why they're sometimes
sensitive after whitening
ouch for an extra benefit some formulas
include sodium acid pyrophosphate and
anti tartar agent it puts a cap on
calcium ions preventing tartar crystals
from building on top of them now go show
off your pearly whites feeling wired yet
subscribe